hey 42 here food is an enormous part of
our lives it affects our moods changes
our bodies it's a key part of our
culture and celebrations and for many of
us is a large part of what we think
about during a day in fact you could go
as far as to say that the whole idea of
civilization is completely down to food
since it was a collaboration we learned
through hunting and then the community
we built through agriculture that
created villages and towns as well as
technology but if you take that Sun
which out your mouth for a second do you
ever wonder how it ended up on your
plate where did they grow the wheat to
make the bread what Pig did the hand
come from why did they put pickles in it
they know you hate pickles all very
important questions so today we are
going to have a quick look at the major
problems facing food glorious food most
of the world is omnivorous we eat meat
and plants although vegetarianism and
veganism are on the rise the numbers are
still relatively low India is way ahead
with 40% of the country being vegetarian
but in almost every other nation it's
well under 10% animal farming or
husbandry as its called
began in the Neolithic era some 12,000
years ago we began to selectively read
the traits we wanted into cattle and
other livestock making them fatter and
more docile because let's be honest
you'd rather deal with this than this
every morning as society grew meat was
more commonly the food of the upper
classes since you needed to invest in
the care of the animals first in order
to eat it especially if you live in a
city so far for many hunting grounds you
can even see this reflected in the
English language the words for meat
generally come from French beef birth
mutton mutton the English royalty
normally spoken French and they were the
ones eating the animals but the lower
classes those of Germanic origin farms
the animals so the actual creek
two names normally come free German and
Dutch cow COO sheep Shack and this leads
us to our current problem as countries
grow richer you can see their meat
consumption increasing since it is seen
as part of a wealthier lifestyle a China
is a great example of this according to
the OECD by 2024 China will be eating
over ten percent more beef almost 25%
more poultry and five percent more pork
but they have a long long way to go to
catch up with the carnivorous
competition the USA is the world's
biggest meat lover chowing down on over
120 kilograms per person every year and
that's the weight of to average adults
just to be clear I'm not saying that
Americans eat people with or without
fava beans Australia and New Zealand are
the only other countries who manage over
100 kilograms annually Australia because
of their barbecue culture and New
Zealand because well what else were they
supposed to do with all those orcs after
the Battle of mordor producing all this
meat uses up an enormous amount of
resources and is one of the biggest
contributors to climate change the main
problem is that at least two are never
ending deforestation especially in South
and Central America since the start of
this video another two square kilometers
of trees have been felled down
they used a lander space for animals but
also they grow feed for them such as
corn and soya and less trees means less
co2 being absorbed from the atmosphere
it also really messes up hide-and-seek
the second issue is that these animals
produce a lot of gas especially cows
methane is a powerful greenhouse gas and
our bovine friends produce 120 kilograms
of it a year that's a thousand times
more than a human
so cows are terrible roommates
especially with their appalling taste in
music the way we keep huge herds of
animals together also means the risk of
disease spreading is far higher than it
used to be and much much faster
outbreaks of things like a V in flavors
in the mass callings of millions of
poultry in an effort to limit it many
animals are given antibiotics but
regulations are changing now since they
become less effective over time and can
lead to the evolution of a super book
what do you think was the first animal
we started breeding of course it was the
dog and we began doing it over 30,000
years ago so that is how long we have
been genetically modifying the life
around us
the huge varieties of breeds of dogs are
all descended from wolves but we have
been using artificial selection as
opposed to natural selection for tens of
thousands of years a scientist called
Dmitri bell you've tried to look at how
the process works by doing the same
thing with foxes in Siberia from 1959 he
started selecting the friendliest foxes
and killing the rest so that their
tameness quality would become a part of
the breed the experiment went on for
some 40 years and they didn't have
anything better to do in Siberia but the
results were pretty impressive the Foxes
could be walked and act as pets the most
interesting part was that they displayed
similar changes to domestic dogs with
their floppy ears and differently
patterned fur just look at a wolf's ears
and then at a dachshund they are so
different but we weren't breeding dogs
to have for four years what would be the
point it turns out that a friendlier
tamer animal is one that has a lower
epinephrine level also called adrenaline
so different hormone levels led to
different physical development it also
affected melanin production which is
what gives the fur its color so that's
why they saw changes there as well our
artificial selection was not limited to
animals of course almost every crop
fruit and vegetable in the supermarket
today has been altered from its original
form by farmers selecting the best
traits that they want and mixing the
plants where they can the lemon is a
great example of this being a hybrid of
the citrus and the bitter orange without
mankind's input it's unlikely that the
lemon would exist in
and no gin and tonic would ever be good
enough then the big jump came with the
discovery of DNA
Frederick Mesa first isolated it in 1869
and then Watson and Crick gave us the
famous double helix structure that we
know today in 1953 by 1982 we had the
first patented GM organism an oil eating
microorganism owned by the Exxon oil
designed to eat up oil spills so how do
you genetically engineer an organism how
do you splice a tomato with a fish for
example this was a real thing bad way
they were using the antifreeze gene of
the white flounder fish to help Tomatoes
survive better in the frost apparently
Hudson scars were not enough so here's a
very basic overview of how genetic
engineering works DNA is a group of
molecules in the form of a double helix
and they combine in pairs to make
strands called chromosomes for humans
there are 46 chromosomes and together
these make up our genomes so it's this
collection of information that makes a
human a human a dog a dog and a cat a
mean ungrateful psychopath with a cute
face you search through genomes for the
traits you want bigger leaves for
example less water usage fishing freeze
proofing whatever you're after then you
isolate the bit of the genome that
manages that trade and you cut it out
using enzymes it's just easier than
scissors apparently you then stick that
bit of the genetic material into a thing
called a plasmid which is sort of like
an extra storage space you find in some
bacteria now you need to put it into the
cells you want to modify you can
literally fire it in with a thing called
a gene gun using tiny metal particles as
bullets you can also use bacteria that
will infect the cells you want to change
and your genetic code can just pop out
like a Trojan jumping out of one of
those wooden horses they love some our
main use for GMOs is as crops and we
used a process to make plants more
resistant to the problems of their
environment potentially giving farmers a
far bigger harvest
in the US alone its reported to have
increased agricultural production by
almost 100 billion dollars the ability
to alter crops quickly if the
environment changes will also be a
massive help especially if you want to
move away from meat consumption so what
is the big controversy around GMOs well
so far there is no scientific evidence
that they are in any way unsafe or
detrimental to human health but many
people wonder if it's such a good idea
to be poking around with life in this
way it's not just a GMOs that we have
changed since they also affect the
environment around them - such as the
animals that need the GMO crops to
survive as we learnt in the documentary
Jurassic Park when you mess about with
life things can go wrong pretty quickly
oh that wasn't a documentary from Mill
g1l lettuce to flies in our soup and
ants in our pants it sometimes feels
like we're in an endless war to keep
pests off our stuff
they are the annoying little brothers of
the animal world and this is why we turn
to our weapon of book destruction the
pesticide for farmers there are a number
of ways you can lose yield animals
insects diseases and weeds as well as
extreme weather events such as droughts
and flooding the yield is the actual
amount of usable product you end up with
so that would be the edible grain for
corn the white fiber for cotton if we
let everything grow completely
unassisted it's estimated we would lose
80% of all cotton 50% of wheat and over
30% of most other key crops there are a
number of ways we try to combat this
such as mechanically tilling the ground
and using software to plant in the best
places at the best times and lots of
others but it is still weeds and insects
that are the biggest issues so we turn
to herbicides and pesticides the
Sumerians are the earliest users of
pesticides using a sulfur compound to
control insects and mites about 4,500
years
ago but as technology developed and our
understanding of plant grew we were able
to create better targeted protections
today one of the most widely used is a
notorious herbicide Roundup made by
Monsanto roundup is mainly glyphosate
and it works by inhibiting an enzyme
called epsp synthase that plants need to
survive but if it kills all plants then
is in that farming genocide well this is
where the GMOs come in companies have
designed crops that don't have an enzyme
that does what epsp does but isn't
affected by roundup okay so if we're
spraying us in our food is it safe um
yes and no you certainly wouldn't want
to do shots of it and it will irritate
your skin if you touch it but given the
huge quantities that I use globally it's
fairly safe to say that it's not
dangerously toxic since most of us are
ingesting traces of it pretty regularly
the World Health Organization have said
that glyphosate is probably a carcinogen
it causes cancer but the amounts
required will be much much higher than
would ever be in the food people are
eating the big issues here are that
since glyphosate kills most plants it
can easily get into the water and damage
the surrounding environment including
aquatic flora there have also been new
weeds appearing that are now resistant
to the herbicide and it's being
suggested that the overuse of glyphosate
has accelerated this process because
evolution is all about repetition so if
you want to avoid pesticides just go
organic right
well I'm afraid not this is one of the
biggest misunderstandings in the
supermarket up there with why haven't
they opened a third lane why is that
woman buying just cat food and ice cream
and were self-service machines invented
by Satan organic farming uses pesticides
all the time they are just not allowed
to use any that's are made synthetically
and they don't use any Jim
there is no specific limit on the volume
of chemical used either so you can end
up spraying a crop seven to eight times
whereas a GMO crop might only need two
sprays the organic food market is now
huge business and one of the world's
leading organic supermarkets Whole Foods
now has a similar revenue to Monsanto
twelve point nine billion dollars to
Monsanto's fifteen point nine billion so
don't expect this fight to end any time
soon the real battleground of the food
industry in the supermarket company's
scrap for prized position on the shelves
and fight it out over prices it's a
shame that no one has accidentally
killed our Brussels sprouts yet no one
likes you sprouts almost nothing in a
supermarket is random the entire layout
and position of each product and
promotion has been carefully calculated
by some very clever algorithms the main
purpose of loyalty cards is not to make
sure you keep coming back to the
supermarket is so they can get some
basic demographical information about
you and then everything you buy is
connected to that data now they can
build profiles of what people of
different ages backgrounds incomes etc
are buying this and determines which
products they promote and how they
layout the aisles basically it's game
over as soon as you walk through the
door do you ever look down at the
mountain of stuff you just bought on the
checkout and think all I wanted was some
milk
but this need for supermarkets to force
consumers to buy endless crap they don't
need leads to one major problem waste
the oranges need to be completely round
the bananas need to be just a right
curve and the sprouts need to be the
perfect flavor of disgusting and then
everything must be labelled or various
expiry date and best-before days and
display until they sort of which are
pretty meaningless it's just there to
act as legal protection for the
supermarket's so that they are always
selling an optimum product thanks to
these factors the world wastes one third
of all the food we produce in fact rich
wastes about 222 million tons every year
which is almost as much food as is
produced in the whole of sub-saharan
Africa in the UK households throw out
about 6.7 million tonnes a year
despite the fact that over 60% of it
could have been eaten if we had just
managed it better to give you an example
the British took out over a million
parts of yoghurt every day unopened but
that date on the Yogesh doesn't mean
it's bad it's just the only day that the
company will guarantee its quality over
- if you're worried about it being full
of bacteria then you clearly don't
understand what a yoghurt is some
countries are now taking steps to limit
this and this year France passed a law
that prevents supermarkets over 400
square meters in size from throwing away
any unsold food now charities and food
banks get the food instead for free to
distribute to the poor and homeless
citizens this puts an end to the
unpleasant practice of deliberately
spoiling food with bleach or other
chemicals to prevent people from taking
it out of the dumpsters another crazy
thing about the supermarket is that when
you walk in and you look at those
never-ending lines of cereals and ice
creams and shower gel and soda feels
like you have an almost infinite choice
but it's all an illusion especially in
the US for Americans almost everything
in the supermarket comes from just 20
companies and that includes the organic
stuff if it's cereal it's probably
Kellogg's or Nestle if it's ice cream
it's probably Unilever if it cleans your
house or your head it's probably prop 2
in Gap try not to get those mixed up
because no one wants pun 10 on that
carpets even meat production is
basically for companies like jbs who
control a quarter of the u.s. cattle in
almost every area of food production
there are just a handful of companies
with a monopoly over the market the
supermarket's themselves are also
enormous walmart for example is the
world's largest corporation
employing over 2 million people and
taking almost 500 billion dollars in
revenue every year that's more than all
of South Africa next up you have the
British Tesco and the membership only
Costco and the French carer for each of
these is about a quarter of the size of
Walmart it's not all doom and gloom the
rise of globalization has given many of
us access to an amazing array of produce
and dishes that would have been
unimaginable just a couple of
generations ago your grandparents would
have been shocked just to find
strawberries in December and there you
are doing sushi into mango chutney
because you ran out of gluten free
pumpkin spiced bagels that is not a good
dinner by the way what would your mother
say thanks for the view subscribe for
more thoughty2
you